Chris Hemsworth may have walked away
from lighting himself on fire all right
but did you know that his fellow Avenger
Jeremy Renner broke both of his arms on
set these are some of the craziest
stunts performed by real actors this was
a pretty tricky sequence to film even
before you get fire involved Chris
Hemsworth had to rehearse this fight
sequence for extraction too for roughly
four or five weeks before filming
because every movie needed to be
incredibly precise in order to get the
shot right and Not only was Chris
fighting against 300 to 400 extras in
the freezing Prague winter his jacket
had also been lit on fire because
according to director Sam Hargrave the
mental image was something that I
couldn't pass up I had to cover my arm
and liquid set it on
for the sequence and of course he
handled it with all the grace of an
Asgardian Prince it was a call not so I
appreciated them off if Chris keeps
these crazy stunts up we're sure to have
another Tom Cruise on our hands here who
needs a stunt double when your star is
Tom Cruise Tom famously does all of his
own stunts including jumping off a
motorcycle from a ramp and deploying a
parachute as he plummets down a
Cliffside for Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one pretty much the
biggest stunt and Cinema history Tom's
always been like this though even as a
kid he used to set up elaborate
death-defying stunts that would put him
in the hospital and the only thing he
learned from that was this is what I
want to do for a living since then he's
flown actual f-18s for top gun Maverick
and he's even dangled from a harness off
an airplane going triple digits through
the air for rogue Nation but none of
these stunts have put his life in danger
so far which is more than Jason Statham
can say Jason Statham is just as
committed to doing his own stunts he's
even performed a choreographed fight
scene while dangling from a helicopter
three thousand feet above Los Angeles
for crank but one stunt for Expendables
3 was so crazy you need to hear this but
maybe consider clicking that subscribe
button first if you don't mind ready
okay so Jason was driving a truck along
the docks of the Black Sea in Bulgaria
when the brakes suddenly failed the
truck hit two cameramen before careening
into the sea 60 feet at the bottom of
the Black Sea stuck in the mud thinking
hang on a minute I'm going to get out of
this Jason was weighed down by his boots
and jacket but that didn't stop him the
survival sort of kicks in and you pull
yourself out the window you stop
grabbing at the war and he managed to
swim to shore where he was met by
Sylvester Stallone asking Jason you knew
the doll it seems that Jason knows as
well as our next entry that stunts
sometimes go wrong when you've done as
many stunts as Jackie Chan has mistakes
are going to happen he dominated the
martial arts scene back in the 1980s
Working With several Hong Kong directors
on some pretty impressive choreography
but it was what he did at the end of
1985's police story that would stay with
the actor forever Jackie had to slide
down a pole covered in lights that would
just explode as he went down before
finally smashing through a pane of glass
at the end
and I said wow safe landing what Jackie
hadn't immediately realized upon Landing
was that the very real light bulbs had
caused the pole to heat up prior to the
stunt being performed then I see all my
hand the the skin pale when Jackie got
over the adrenaline he realized that he
suffered second-degree burns all over
his palms hooray Jackie isn't the only
actor to have done incredible things out
of adrenaline
007 is synonymous with action when
Daniel Craig took on the role of James
Bond he knew that it would come with
having to perform as many action scenes
himself as he could if they were
confident enough to let me do them I
should do them because it's my face I
think people can tell the chief stunt
coordinator on Quantum of Solace and
Casino Royale Gary Powell even praised
Daniel for putting the work in if it's
something he's not keen on like for one
thing Daniel isn't a lover of heights
but that didn't stop him from jumping
out of a three-story window and onto a
moving bus for Quantum of Solace I just
had to sort of breathe production on the
Bond films had been delayed a few times
because of injuries Daniels gained from
performing stunts even getting two of
his front teeth knocked out while
performing fight choreography for Casino
Royale All Things Considered it's hard
to say if he's having as much fun as our
next entry you've never seen piano this
excited about anything before the
Beloved actor has performed his fair
share of thrilling stunts in the John
Wick movies having made it clear that
he's 90 of what's happening there but
when it comes to the craziest and
potentially keanu's favorite stunt he's
ever performed that would have to be the
time that he had to jump off of a
46-story building for Matrix
resurrections it was awesome can you
imagine just leaping off of a building
he had to keep going over the stunt
around 19 20 times Allah along with his
co-star carrianne moss and although she
had to mentally prepare hanu didn't
quite get the fear of heights he said
that you just can't think about these
things like fear when you have a job to
do and then just be there and do
and that's what we did it seems Keanu
may share Harrison Ford's Daredevil
Spirit now Harrison Ford made movie
history with this stunt do you remember
the famous Boulder scene from Indiana
Jones well I bet that you didn't realize
that Harrison was actually running away
from the Rolling prop himself it wasn't
a real Rock obviously but it was around
800 pounds worth of wood plaster and
fiberglass that stood at about 12 feet
high Steven Spielberg wanted to get five
shots of the Rock from five different
angles meaning that Harrison had to race
The Rock 10 times he won 10 times and
beat the odds Spielberg noted that he
was lucky and I was an idiot for letting
him try it not all actors are as lucky
take Jeremy Renner for instance but
Harrison has been doing these sorts of
stunts his whole career Harrison was
more recently injured while rehearsing a
fight scene for Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny and yet he's shown no
sinus slowing down anytime soon of
course Jeremy Renner is also familiar
with not letting an injuries slow him
down but between snowmobiling and Wind
River or motorcycle racing in The Bourne
Legacy you wouldn't think it was the
stunt from a comedy movie tag that wound
up being his most memorable Jeremy was
being chased by his co-stars up a number
of chairs that were stacked about 20
feet high and when the rigging broke
Jeremy says I broke along with it and
fell on the ground Jeremy didn't realize
that anything was wrong at first but was
concerned enough to go to the hospital
where he found out yeah it has broken
both my arms ouch still Jeremy was such
a trooper he got splints in both arms
and still came back to filming that day
they just had to CGI over his cast which
makes us wonder if fear of injury has
ever made Angelina Jolie that could have
been stunned honestly Angelina isn't
thinking injury at all when she does
stunts she's thinking about her kids but
maybe not in the way you expect they're
actually her motivation to do cool
stunts Angelina became real familiar
with using harnesses when she was
filming for Lara Croft Tomb Raider but
the bungee thing is just it's fun and
still found ways to wow audiences by
leaping from a bridge to a moving truck
in the movie Salt when discussing her
action scenes for the movie those who
wish me dead Angelina said that you're
so lucky as an actor because even if
you're doing a big crazy stunt and
you're on top of a truck on a freeway
doing your thing you have your rig it's
been tested so you get to be pretty
brave and have a lot of people looking
after you that may be the case for her
but if we're talking Burt Reynolds his
rig hadn't exactly been tested even the
direct doctor thought this stunt was a
bad idea for a scene in the 1972 movie
Deliverance where his character's canoe
goes over a 25-foot waterfall Burt
Reynolds insisted on doing the stunt
himself even when director John Borman
had wanted to use a dummy instead but
Bert got his way only for his canoe to
hit a rock on the way down causing him
to nearly drown the water shot him up
Like a Torpedo and he was found by the
crew 15 minutes later completely naked
Bert would also suffer a tailbone injury
through all this that would continue to
cause him pain for the rest of his life
later on in life Bert would admit that
when it's cold and I'm limping around he
would wonder why he hadn't let his stunt
double take a couple more scenes for him
adding that it was a dumb Macho thing we
aren't surprised to hear of actors like
Burt Reynolds who grew to regret pushing
themselves to such extremes but we're
still glad to hear of examples like
Keanu Reeves who are still having fun
surprising us which of these absolutely
insane stunts were you the most
surprised to hear about and are there
any other examples we might have missed
make sure to let us know down in the
comment section